set in the techno futuristic city of
detroit detroit become human is a
narrative driven choice laden adventure
brought to you by quantum green and
david cage
it is a readily believable world
in which androids and humans exist in a
slave and master relationship
a reality that may come to pass in our
own future and it is this potential
similarity which rise much of the
narrative in detroit become human
revolving around the trio of androids
corner cara and marcus
quantic dream weaves a grand tale this
is a title that touts choices which
matter
and it does not disappoint
each of the android story is filled with
their own signature flair
conor wrestles with his duty of
completing his mission as a deviant
hunter
while balancing his relationship with
his human partner
cara is a catholic android that has to
deal with an abusive father and helpless
daughter
and marcus starts from humble beginnings
as an artist assistant to becoming the
face of revolution
with a flowchart option that shows you
the many different ways any scene can
turn out
detroit become human is a game with
immense replay value there are simple
straightforward experiences and then
there are overlapping experiences that
draw from your many decisions to create
a humongous tree of consequences
if there is one thing to criticize
detroit become human about
the controls could do with a little more
fine-tuning
movement is still heavy and clunky
and pathing remains an issue
the decision to map certain actions and
the camera to the right analog stick
can cause issues with finding the right
perspective as well
detroit become human does a decent job
in exploring the ideas it is purporting
in the run-up to the game's release
there was a particular focus on the more
controversial aspects of the game like
depicting domestic abuse
but overall the ideas were explored with
respect and done well
and should not deter anyone from trying
out the game
not only do your three characters get
meaningful top provoking arcs
the world itself grows and changes in
ways that will keep you on edge of your
seat
even better the supporting cast of
characters are great supplements to the
main trio
while the stories are not as fully
fleshed out the interesting nuggets of
information that you may discover will
often give you an insight into diablo
and detroit as a whole
it is not surprising to feel emotionally
invested in the happenings of the city
as well as the many characters you play
and meet when combined with the stunning
visuals and awesome soundtrack it
becomes an all-sensory experience
the facial capture is phenomenal the
voice acting superb
and it certainly helps sell the
emotional stakes of the game
detroit became human had many things
going against it leading up to release
but the time spent in a sublimely
realized world was an emotional roller
coaster
sprinkled with terrific characters
unforgettable performances and a
believable narrative that hooks you in
at a return
with both heavy rain and beyond two
soles in the belt it is safe to say that
chronic dreams detroit become human
takes everything good about its
predecessors and adding even more
aaa magic for an unforgettable and
memorable time it is truly a pinnacle of
choice-based storytelling like no other
[Music]